c'est l'heure du souper chez isabelle
lefebvre au menu filet de porc teria qui
rit asperges et autres légumes dans la
préparation 0 la mère de famille à
réchauffer les plats achetés d'un
service de prêt-à-manger séquence est en
marche de restaurant chez nous et c'est
une qualité aussi bonne qu au resto elle
commande en ligne et fait livrer à sa
porte chaque semaine plus de la moitié
des repas pour nourrir la famille
un investissement de 100 à 170 dollars
qui lui permet de gagner du temps et de
souffler un peu
en fait les laisse en fait les devoirs
on a le temps de jouer à des jeux de
société les soirs de 6,9
chose que je ne pouvais pas faire avant
c'est lui qui a changé la vie d'isabelle
antoine masson de lille a lancé son
entreprise de prêt-à-manger il y a dix
ans on a vingt à vingt-cinq clubs
différents chaque semaine des menus
changent tout le temps l'aventuré a
commencé dans la cuisine de ses parents
depuis antoine au quotidien ne cesse de
grandir
en ce moment on fait 400 mais comment
par semaine on aimerait ce dans un
avenir de deux à trois ans triplé 4
milliards de dollars en 2019
le marché des plats préparés y est en
pleine croissance au pays
les supermarchés en ont pris bonne note
l'offre s'est grandement diversifiée au
delà du traditionnel poulet barbecue
provigo a lancé sa propre marque de
prêt-à-manger il y a deux a scellé canal
ni à la viande des options populaires
auprès de la jeune génération
44% des milléniaux font appel au prêt à
manger
contrairement aux bébés mots pour un
soir seulement 14%
il ya un peu de tout dans le prg et à
manger des repas très santé d'autres un
peu moins
c'est comme des plats de dépannage est
ce qu'on devrait manger c'est tout
l'effort non selon ce nutritionniste
il faut faire particulièrement attention
aux plats vendus en épicerie
qu'est ce qu'on a comme ingrédient la
dent est ce que ça se rapproche de nos
recettes maison
si oui ça vaut le coup peut-être de
payer pour le service la personne qui a
cuisiné pour nous priego qualité
plusieurs critères sont à considérer ici
olivier cachin radio canada montréal